we're asked to find the cube root of
negative 343 or another way to think
about it is some number that when I
multiply it by itself three times I'm
going to get negative 343 or another way
to view it this is the same thing as
negative 343 to the 1/3 power and the
best way to do this is to really just
try to factor this out so the first
thing we could do so let me just factor
negative 343 so the first thing I'd like
to do is just factor out the negative
one so the same thing as negative one
times
343 and let's think about this is this
divisible by two
no is it just by three see the digits do
not add up to a multiple of three they
add up to ten so it's not divisible by
three not divisible by four since it's
odd not just by five because it doesn't
end with a five or zero it's not
divisible by six because it's not
divisible by 2 or three is it divisible
by seven let's check this out so 7 goes
into 343 seven goes into 34 4 times 4
times 7 is 28 4 34-28 is going to be 6
bring down the 3 7 goes into 63 exactly
9 times so and then we end up so 9 times
7 is 63 no remainder so this is going to
be 7 times 49 and we know that 49 is the
same thing as 7 times 7 so how can we
rewrite this this is the same thing as
taking is the same thing as taking the
cube root the cube root of negative 1 of
negative 1 times 7 times 7 times 7 which
is the same thing as taking the cube
root of negative 1 times the cube root
the cube root of 7 times 7 times 7 now
what's the cube root of negative 1 well
negative 1 times itself 3 times is
negative 1 so this right here is
negative 1 you can verify negative 1
times negative 1 times negative 1 is
indeed negative 1 this becomes positive
1 multiplied by negative 1 again you get
negative
so this is negative one and then this
over here the cube root of 7 times 7
times 7 well that's just going to be 7 7
multiplied by itself 3 times gives us 7
times 7 times 7 or 343 so it's going to
be negative 1 times 7 which is the same
thing as negative 7 so our answer is
negative 7 and we're done